bangladesh is one of the world's largest
tea producers the industry employs more
than 150 000 people at more than 200
plantations
most of the workers are female they work
long hours and earn some of the lowest
wages in the country
luchi kandu and her husband both work on
a plantation they say little has changed
for tea workers over the generations
we hardly get any type of facilities
don't have enough money for our
children's education we barely get three
kilograms of flour as rations once a
week some days we don't even get to eat
which is why we are protesting
bangladesh export tea to more than 20
countries including the us uk and
tea france want their minimum wage to be
raised they earn slightly more than a
dollar a day now
we have been protesting for 12 days now
the owners don't understand our play we
have been demanding our daily wage be
raised to 3 a day then we will go back
to work
plantation owners say they are going
through difficult times with profits
declining in recent years
in reality what they are saying is not
right we provide a medical fund
retirement benefit along with weekly
rations and access to primary education
for the children it all adds up to
around four dollars a day
late on saturday the government proposed
a wage hike of 25 cents a day but it was
rejected by the workers
[Music]
the administration has used intimidation
and threats to pressure the workers
union to accept the government's latest
proposal of a pay hike but since the tea
garden students organization and workers
have rejected it and protested now the
union has also rejected it
the stories of these workers may sound
like myths to many but it's their daily
reality the tea workers and their unions
have pledged to continue their strike
until their demand for pay hike is met
the un says they are one of the most
marginalized groups in the country with
limited access to basic facilities and
education
recent strikes by the tea workers of
bangladesh have become a railing point
for many here as rising inflation and
high food prices add to the wider
frustration about low wages chanwi
choudhary al-jazeera sri mango